tierversuche finde ich super schwieriges
thema und tierversuche finde ich auch
nicht verlassen
ich könnte jetzt zum beispiel nicht den
hund meines nachbarn in einem versuch
einschleusen das ginge zum beispiel
nicht das könnte ich nicht über mich
bringen meinen atmet hat so die letzten
atemzüge auch noch mit und das erste mal
brauchte ich natürlich danach erstmal
lag
hey ich bin froh
physiker und biologen und ich mache hier
versuche ich bin lieber ich studiere
medizin und ich arbeite mit meinem bett
und ich hab pharmazie studiert und habe
immer meine masterarbeit mit mäusen
gearbeitet der wendeplatz turm geforscht
das sind die meisten hier in tumore die
es gibt also die bösartigsten im rahmen
meiner doktorarbeit untersuchen wir wie
sich das gehirn im rahmen von
chronischen erkrankungen verändert und
kennt das ja es gibt viele leute in der
hirnforschung die irgendwelche
krankheiten untersuchen
alles sah man abhaken sind was auch
immer und ich stelle die frage so ein
bisschen umgekehrt also nicht wie geht
unser gehirn kaputt sondern warum
passiert ist eigentlich ständig
die operation war stereotaktische
operation stereotaktische heißt die maus
wird
statisch festgehalten
dann wären gewisse koordinaten genommen
um diese krebszellen genau in dieses
hier in aria industrie atom zu pflanzen
damit ist dort an wächst um sie dann mit
medikamenten zu behandeln um zu schauen
ob der krebs zurück geht oder wenigstens
die migration und so ein tag an dem ich
untersuchung gemacht habe habe ich
morgens erstmal die eine hatte die ich
untersuchen wollte aus der tierhaltung
abgeholt mit dem aufzug mit ihrer
hochgefahren habe dann einige minuten
mit ihr gespielt den arm genommen sie
unter meine axel gehalten weil sie sich
hatten da unglaublich wohl fühlen schön
dunkel schön warm und danach habe ich
sie einschlafen lassen und mit
einschlafen wenn ich nicht einschläfern
sondern sie hat ein betäubungsmittel
bekommen und danach weil ich eher ins
gehirn sehen wollte und sehen wollte was
passiert wenn sie bestimmte töne hört
und welche bereiche des gehirns da was
tut musste ich eine öffnung in ihren
schädel machen damit ich mit dem
mikroskop hineinschauen kann
das heißt ich habe dann ihrem kopf
rasiert einfach mit demselben rasierer
den ich auch zu hause habe also mit so
einem sonnenbad trümmer und dann kamen
wir ganz schwierigen moment nämlich der
moment wo ich mit der mit der op der
chirurgie anfangen muss der moment in
dem ich gewusst habe jetzt geht es los
und jetzt mache ich ein tierversuch
während dieser op schaltet man rechts
und links aus man macht diese op man
will die maus nicht länger als nötig in
der narkose haben seine er so kurz wie
möglich und da ist es protokollarisch
man macht diese op und rechts und links
ist verschwendet man sieht nur noch vor
sich hella hahm noch im haar mein
werkzeug und so wollte man wird sehr
technisch man sieht auch nicht die
massen für sich man sieht eine schere
man macht das ein schädel auf man sieht
den schädel kopf man nimmt die
koordinaten es ist anstrengend das ist
halt auch sehr intensiv für ein man
sieht ja wenn ich die maus an für sich
sondern erst nach der op wenn sie sich
dann wieder putzen und wenn man wirklich
so denkbar
ich habe dieser was diese op angetan
leben trotzdem fast hand putzen sich ja
und wenn man sie halt wirklich so
lebendig sieht dann tut sein irgendwo
wenn der versuchung ist dann kommt das
alles wieder und man hat ja nicht
vergessen was man da tut und das ist das
eine ratte ist ich könnte jetzt zum
beispiel nicht den hund meines nachbarn
in einem versuch einschleusen das ginge
zum beispiel nicht das könnte ich nicht
über mich bringen da ist zu viel zu viel
erinnerungen zu viel beziehungen zu dem
tier
ich glaube dass das davon auch nicht
nicht haben wenn man versuche macht dass
man tieren zum beispiel namen gibt
wirklich und die dann behandelt wie ein
eigenes haustier ich glaube das würde
einen selber auch ich würde eigentlich
guttun ich hatte auch als ich angefangen
hatte ich nach so einem buch geschenkt
bekommen schilder ab verkehren und das
war ein kinderbuch über eine maus konnte
ich natürlich nicht weiterleben weil ich
dann mit mäusen gearbeitet habe
aber wenn ich mir vorstelle kleine
schilder ab weil sie halt irgendwie eine
personifizierung dort hat kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen so eine kleine cd tour
wirklich einzusetzen
wenn der therapie fertig ist um dann
endpoint zu bekommen ob die therapie
angeschlagen hat oder nicht werden die
mäuse organisiert und getötet also
eingeschläfert mit co2 und dort danach
wird die schädeldecke aufgemacht das
gehirn rausgenommen um dann früher also
es wird dann eingefroren
und ganz ganz kleine schnitte genommen
um die dann unterm mikroskop zu schauen
ob der tumor zurückgegangen ist und ob
die therapie angeschlagen hat ich habe
täglich mit den tieren verbracht man
gewöhnt sich an die tiere
sie gewöhnen sich auch an einem selber
es wird natürlich super light wenn man
sowas einschläfern muss und dass er mit
co2 man atmet die letzten atemzüge auch
noch mit und das erste mal brauchte ich
natürlich danach erstmal lag das töten
von den tieren von den studien tieren
gehört immer zudem versuchen dazu es ist
geplant am ende jedes versuchs also bei
mir nach ein paar monaten das heißt das
töten von tieren ist auch ein
bestandteil ganz klar von meiner arbeit
schön ist das töten von den tieren nicht
ich kenne niemanden der das irgendwie
leichten herzens tut in meinem fall
liegt es daran vor allem dass wir die
die gehirne von den mäusen auch brauchen
um die weiter zu untersuchen um
möglichst viel wissen von den tieren
auch zu gewinnen
das heißt da komme ich nicht drum rum
die tiere am ende auch töten zu müssen
wenn ich am ende der versuche die rate
dann töten musste war das für mich immer
noch sehr sehr emotionale sache ich habe
ja dann ja ich hab sie dann in die hand
genommen ich habe dann eine spritze
gegeben mit einem betäubungsmittel mit
einer überdosis von betäubungsmitteln
und hab dann eben das getan was beim
tierarzt einschläfern heißt aber das
bedeutet eben ich habe sie getötet
es gibt auch noch andere gründe warum
man tiere auch während
eines versuchs oder während der
eigentliche versucht noch läuft töten
muss das ist zum beispiel wenn man merkt
dass das tier leidet wenn das aus
irgendwelchen gründen schmerzen hat oder
das sieht man den mäusen an es gibt
kriterien wo man sagt diesem dieser maus
geht es dich gut die zeit
verhaltensauffälligkeiten oder sieht so
und so aus da sollte man den versuch
beenden und die maus dann auch töten
nach manchen versuchen hier ist man sich
jetzt eben nicht sicher hieß der maus
geht es der rat geht es jetzt richtig
gut
oder hat die möglicherweise noch ein
bisschen schmerzen und wenn ich dir
jetzt am leben lasse hat die dann morgen
schmerzen nächste woche monate
vielleicht jahre lang schmerzen wenn man
sich nicht absolut sicher ist dass es
dem tier gut geht dann muss das tier
unbedingt getötet werden hat man gar
keine wahl
tierversuche finde ich super schwieriges
thema und tierversuche finde ich auch
recht belastend und deswegen habe ich
vor fast zehn jahren auch tatsächlich
weil damit aufgehört der versuche zu
machen
seit zwei jahren arbeitet mache ich
jetzt wieder tierversuche ich habe ja
jahrelang nur computersimulationen
gemacht nur theoretisch gearbeitet auch
in der hirnforschung genau dasselbe
forschungsthema aber ganz andere
methoden und dann habe ich gemerkt ich
kann irgendwie alles simulieren und das
gegenteil davon
und es ist nur so nur dann nützlich wenn
ich es ab und zu auch damit vergleichen
kann was eben wirklich in meinem gehirn
passiert ist eine adäquate als in der
tiefe sinn wie viele studien geben würde
ich auch sofort machen wenn es ohne
tierversuche ginge dann würden wir
garantiert auch keine tierversuche
machen
niemand macht tierversuche gerne weil es
tiere sind und wir gerne mit tieren
arbeiten sondern weil wir es müssen
gerade in den neurowissenschaften ist
die arbeit mit dem tier unentbehrlich so
etwas komplexes wie das zentrale
nervensystem lässt sich leider noch
nicht modellieren deswegen habe ich mich
entschieden dass ich wieder tierversuche
machen will und hat mir eben zebrafische
rausgesucht auf deutsch heißen
eigentlich zebra wermelinger die gibt es
auch zum beispiel beim hornbach in der
zweiten abteilung die schau mir aber die
ganz kleinen fische an das heißt
verschlafen und weil sie durchsichtig
sind kann ich ihnen ohne sie
aufzuschneiden ohne op direkt ins gehirn
schauen fisch versuche fallen mir auch
nicht viel einfacher muss ich sagen also
fische das klingt jetzt muss auch ja gut
na das ist ja nur ein fisch aber wenn
man den fischen halt dabei zusieht wie
sie wie sie schlüpfen wie sie wie sie
aufwachsen wie sie wie sie größer werden
das ist schon auch sehr emotional wenn
ich wenn ich sie dann irgendwann auch
sterben sie
wenn man plan hat für tierversuche von
dem man sagt der könnte nützlich sein
dann sollte man die immer in dem tier
machen das am wenigsten drunter leidet
und auch in möglichst wenigen tieren
diese versuche machen und für mich
persönlich die fragen die mich
interessieren die sind so grundlegend
dass ich nur verstehen will wie
funktioniert endlich die die sprache der
nervenzellen
das ist die grammatik in der sich die
zellen mit man laut erhalten das kann
ich genauso gut im fisch untersuchen wie
in der arena machen wie einem menschen
und weil wir davon ausgehen dass fische
unter dieser art von untersuchung
weniger leiden als zb warten würde ich
diesen versuch nicht in der rather
machen
ich finde raten versuche prinzipiell
nach wie vor vernünftig und ich finde
sie auch nach wie vor ethisch vertretbar
ich selbst will sie eigentlich nicht
mehr machen
das ist ja oft so dass man sagt es gibt
was das finde ich zwar an sich richtig
aber mir persönlich ist es doch
unangenehm und ich bin froh wenn es
jemand anders übernimmt
eine persönliche grenze bei mir
bezüglich tierversuchen wäre es
einerseits auf jeden fall wenn ich nicht
selber überzeugt bin dass das was ich
mache wirklich nimmt zweck dient von dem
ich auch überzeugt bin dass er ein guter
zweck ist das ist das eine also auch die
banalsten tierversuche würde ich nicht
machen wenn ich denke das ist unsinn an
sich der versuchsaufbau oder die
fragestellung methodisch was ich nicht
machen würde mit mit ihren generell ist
oder wären versuche bei denen die tiere
ganz offensichtlich stark leiden und das
stark leiden nicht als abrufs kriterium
gilt
mich würde das schon belasten wenn ich
merke der maus geht es jetzt echt nicht
gut aber sie muss ich muss jetzt weiter
für den versuch benutzen weil das
dazugehört das wäre für mich jetzt so
nicht machbar glaub ich da war für mich
persönlich die grenze
auch eben weiterem freundeskreis ein
paar freunde die sich sehr für den
tierschutz engagieren und auch sehr
überzeugt sind dass tierversuche der
vergangenheit angehören sollten
der tierfreund ist tatsächlich die erste
zeitschrift die jemals abonniert hatte
und das hat sich auch nicht geändert
also ich glaube es ist kein gegensatz
erst mal daran dass man sagt ich bin
tierfreund oder dass man sagt ich bin
tierschützer und ich bin trotzdem nicht
prinzipiell gegen tierversuche als wär
mir sogar sehr recht wenn wenn alle
leute die sagen hey ich bin tierfreund
dass die sich irgendwie mit
tierversuchen auseinandersetzung und
genau von den leuten würde ich mir
wünschen dass die tierversuche machen
wenn es schon jemand macht weil ich mir
bei denen sicher sein kann die kümmern
sich halt wirklich um das tier und die
machen nur das was was nötig ist und
sind eben so dass auch fertig
ich habe auch noch einen jagdschein ich
wünsche mir damit groß geworden meine
zwei großeltern hatten auch den
jagdschein und mit denen es man die
natur man hat sie tiere gesehen auch
ziemlich nah man ist zum beispiel zu
einem fuchsbau gegangen und hat den
fuchs gekannt man könnte auch den fuchs
an der kleinen jungen bekommen und wie
dieser nach dem auf der wiese herum
tollen und dann würde man auch mal
mitgenommen auf die jagd durch die jagd
ich esse fleisch und ich bin ziemlich
auch nicht der verantwortung ein stück
wild zu erlegen ich werde sie in der
lage dazu in lam zu töten deswegen esse
ich auch keinen lohn
ich kann mich noch erinnern als ich mein
erstes stück fleisch hatte wusste ich
erst mal wie viel arbeit dahinter steht
um dieses fleisch überhaupt essen zu
dürfen
der schuss ist unter verantwortung eines
jeden jägers und man will das tier so
wenig wie möglich leiden sehen und man
will den schuss so abgeben dass man so
viel wie möglich vom tier verwerten kann
wenn man es falsch abgekommen ist und
das irgendwie leiden muss was mir zum
glück noch nicht passiert dann ist man
traurig man will also leid an tieren zu
hören zu sehen
das macht traurig aber ein stück tier zu
erschießen wenn es noch nicht mal
gemerkt wenn es einfach umgekippt und
dann nicht mal gemerkt hat dass es jetzt
tut es mich nicht traurig ja also wenn
man sie ersticken seht es vielleicht
auch ein tod jetzt nicht man kann es ja
nicht erschießen aber die letzten
atemzügen von den mäusen darf da sieht
man halt doch selber keines wie soll ich
sagen
es berührt ich bin keine vegetarierin
leider könnte man sagen also ich glaube
es hat sehr sehr viele gründe warum man
vegetarier
vegetarier sein sollte ich mache ich es
einfach ausgenutzt und weil mein freund
leider supergut gerichte macht mit
fleisch willem ich glaube ich auch
schlechter keine vegetarierin zu sein
als dafür dass ich meine tierversuche
mache weil in meiner wahrnehmung ist das
fleischessen verzichtbare als das was
wir im labor tun
ich bin kein veganer aber ich esse fast
kein fleisch mehr
ich denke da schon sehr bewusst darüber
nach eben auch die tiere durch die
tierversuche und ich glaube es gibt auch
fast niemanden der tierversuche macht
den ich ständig darüber nachdenkt was
bedeutet dass tiere zu benutzen
als wären sie dass sie sind ja keine
sache das weiß ich ja auch und trotzdem
gibt es eben manchmal fälle wo ich sage
ich bin bereits ein tier leid zuzufügen
ganz sicher in der hoffnung dass dadurch
einem anderen tier wie zum beispiel den
menschen irgendwann später leid erspart
hat
mal labor war unter anderem auch in der
uniklinik thüringen und ich bin
tagtäglich an den patienten vorbei
gelaufen die bestrahlt werden und mir
tut er leid dass ich diesen patienten
nicht helfen kann also momentan nicht
helfen kann hatte dann aber halt auch
jeden tag dieses ziel vor augen ok in
den patienten in der nächsten
generationen
ich versuche dann den leuten zu erklären
warum ich das tue was ich tue und dass
sich auch diese gedanken habe dass ich
auch mir überlege warum mache ich das
und bin ich überzeugt dass das was ich
du richtig ist und am ende irgendwann
hilft den menschen in dem fall also das
kann man jetzt nicht leugnen wenn ich
die mäuse fragen würde ob sie damit
machen wollen was ich mit ihnen tun die
sind natürlich möchte keine maus eine
labormaus sein dass man an tieren
forscht und der spezies mensch zu helfen
kann ist ja auch irgendwie sehr menschen
zentriert sehr egozentrisch und da
verstehe ich den gedanken gut dass man
das befremdlich findet das vollkommen ok
für oder gegen tierversuche zu sein und
es gibt gute gründe gegen tierversuche
zu sein
es gibt schlechte gründe gegen
tierversuche zu sein genauso wie es gute
und schlechte gründe gibt dafür zu sein
und wir können darüber reden
auch an der uni auch im studium und ich
glaube da könnten wir noch einiges tun
ich hatte einen ziemlich coolen job also
ich hab mir nicht viel geld
es reicht juni für ein zimmer wohnungen
in einem plattenbau mit der richtig
hübschen blick hier raus auf die straße
pause nach thüringen den super zufrieden
so richtig reich wirst du natürlich
nicht an der uni
aber es ist ein genialer job weil ich
was machen kann von dem ich das gefühl
habe das ist irgendwie sinnvoll den job
habe ich weil die gesellschaft sich
irgendwie als ganze also alle leute da
draußen sich gesagt haben hey wir zahlen
super gerne steuern damit der kerne hier
irgendwie wissenschaftler sein kann und
das mindeste was ich da zurückgeben kann
ist nicht nur dass ich meine arbeit
ordentlich machen und dass ich alles
sauber dokumentiere dass das nachher
irgendjemand verwenden kann sondern dass
sie auch bereit bin den leuten immer zu
erklären moment was mache ich da
eigentlich und warum mache ich das und
was genau sind die regeln und wer bin
ich überhaupt der ich diesen job
übernommen habe
das finde ich super wichtig dass ich
halt auch in der verantwortung stehe
gerade als jemand der für den staat
arbeitet an einer uni klinik forschung
macht dass ich auch bereit bin raus zu
gehen und den leuten zu sagen hey hier
bin ich und ihr könnt mir fragen stellen